so I got to ask you did you always
Envision coming back to the disenchanted
world or did this kind of like come out
of left field for you
not left field no I think um we had been
talking about it for a couple years and
it had gone through a couple different
incarnations and finally when everyone
was free at one time it came together
yeah not a lot has changed in the last
15 years my main concern is every scene
we see you in you're wearing a fancy
poofy dress so has like fancy poofy
dress technology gotten better in the
last 15 years is it more comfortable has
it even changed
no it just has not changed it's the more
you cinch in the corset the more you
would love to have a rib removed and it
makes it really hard to eat lunch or
dinner on your break and you have to sit
on very you have to sit on these funny
chairs they're like little tiny stools
without a back because you just want to
plop down and put the skirt over it and
if you have a back then you can't get
the skirt over it
that's the glamor yeah that's the glamor
everyone's looking for is it is there a
uh a Disney World a Disney movie or TV
world that you always thought to
yourself ugh I would love to live in
that that would be a fairy tale
perfection
whenever I get asked this question I
never think of a princess thing which
would probably be more relevant I the
first movie I ever saw was Lady and the
[ __ ] and so for me it was yeah thinking
about sitting at an Italian restaurant
and uh with my my love and sucking on
spaghetti
I love that
um Patrick Dempsey has said that this
was like the first time is ever sang in
public
um number one how do you do number two
did he come because you're the expert
here did he come to you for any tips any
advice
[Laughter]
um he doesn't need my advice everyone on
the in the cast is supremely talented
um and there's lots of singing and
dancing when the camera wasn't rolling
as well
um I'm really happy for him he has a
wonderful moment when we first met in
Enchanted we took these Waltzing lessons
together so I've known that he's uh
really uh talented in the dancing
um scenario
so he's got fancy footwork then yes he
does
whenever we get a musical like this it
always really feels like an event you
know it's not that these don't come
around very often
um why do you think it is that you know
whenever we do get a film like this
Enchanted where it's just a celebration
of music and dancing people will really
flock to it will really still connect to
it
um I just think music is the universal
language I think that life can be
difficult and we all are really in need
of an uplifting joyous storyline
um we are brought back to the days of
old when
um where when people sang their feelings
um it was a glorious thing and I just
think it brings people together you know
and it's a great way for the holidays
for everyone to for families to sit and
watch something that they all can relate
to yeah you've also got uh an uplifting
and joyous story hopefully of your own
coming with your documentary yeah this
is going to be I'm fascinated by the
journey that you're going to take us on
with this why did you why did you want
to share this particular
um part of your story and your journey
with people well selfishly I did it
because I really wanted to document a
dream coming true for myself I had
always wanted to play at Madison Square
Garden having grown up in Long Island
and going to college in New York City it
was just a place that you would dream to
play and when it was actually happening
I just wanted to bottle that you know
and then when I did get all the footage
and start when and then when I did
um start filming it on tour I realized
that it was so much more than just a
tour documentary it was a life
documentary it was a it was a film about
wanting to be the best mom the best wife
and also continue and live my dream and
my passion of Performing and trying to
do that all at one time
very cool and well I'm very excited uh
congratulations on this film as well
great to talk to you thank you thank you
so much